today we're going to talk about the
armenian language the official language
of armenia a country located up in the
mountains of the armenian highlands it's
spoken by between six and seven million
people around three million of them in
armenia others live in nearby areas
where armenians have historically lived
or in the armenian diaspora throughout
the world if i were to ask you which
language family the armenian language
belonged to what would you say number
one turkic number two indo-european
number three semitic number four
cartwheelian like georgian the answer is
four kartvelian
actually i lied it's number two
indo-european that means it's related to
languages like english spanish russian
and hindi but unlike most other branches
of the indo-european language family
which have numerous members armenian
forms its own independent branch of
indo-european by itself
some linguists think that armenian greek
and the indo-iranian languages may have
formed a common branch in the distant
past but diverged from each other very
early on
the armenian alphabet was created in the
early 5th century by the christian monk
mesrop mashtots and the earliest known
armenian text a translation of the bible
was written soon after we don't know
much about the language before then but
the recorded history of the armenian
people in this land dates back to at
least the 6th century bc but there's
other evidence that they were present
before 1200 bc
one precursor to the armenian nation may
have been the hayasa azi confederation
the languages spoken there are unknown
but the name hayasa seems to resemble
the word for armenia in armenian
hayastan and the adjective for armenian
hi
there's evidence that the armenians were
present in the kingdom of urartu because
there are words in armenian that were
borrowed from the extinct urartian
language
armenia known by that name arose as a
political entity after the fall of
urartu but has come under the rule of
many different empires
under all of these rulers the armenian
people spoke an earlier form of armenian
but there was contact with other
languages and armenian underwent a
significant amount of influence from
them for instance it was influenced by
parthian a northwestern iranian language
and lingua franca of the parthian empire
then later by middle persian a
southwestern iranian language and lingua
franca of the sasanian empire that
succeeded the parthian empire a large
number of parthian and middle persian
words were adopted into classical
armenia which lasted from the 5th
century to the 11th century speakers of
persian and other indo-iranian languages
can still recognize a lot of words of
persian and parthian origin today for
example the word for thousand in
armenian
and in persian hazard the word for bad
in armenian vat and in persian bad in
both cases the armenian words were
borrowed from middle persian those are
just a couple of examples but there are
other words that are cognates with
persian ones that were not borrowed but
go all the way back to
proto-indo-european for example the word
for man in armenian mart and in persian
mert armenian may have also borrowed
from some extinct anatolian languages
such as hittite and louien as well as
semitic languages like arabic syriac and
assyrian and armenian may have a
caucasian substrate meaning that it
contains influence from a caucasian
language whose speakers adopted armenian
it was also influenced by turkic
languages under seldrick rule and
ottoman rule for example in its noun
agglutination the way multiple
grammatical suffixes are attached to
noun stems there has also been some
russian vocabulary borrowed into eastern
armenia
why do i need to specify eastern
armenian the historic land of armenia
was politically partitioned for much of
its history with western armenia and
eastern armenia coming under different
rulers the byzantine empire versus the
sassanid empire the ottoman empire
versus the safawi empire and the ottoman
empire versus the russian empire this
resulted in the development of two
spheres of the armenian language with
western and eastern dialects undergoing
different developments and with the
establishment of two standard varieties
western armenian based partly on the
constantinople dialect and eastern
armenian based partly on the yerevan
dialect but these standard varieties
differ from all spoken dialects of which
there are many eastern armenian is
official in armenia and is used in the
disputed territory of artsakh and by
armenian communities in russia georgia
and iran western armenian is used by the
remaining armenian community in turkey
istanbul in particular as well as in
much of the armenian diaspora throughout
the middle east and the rest of the
world the features and examples i talk
about in this video will be from eastern
armenian but first a message from our
sponsor me did you know that i have a
second channel on the geofocus channel
which i recently rebooted after a five
year hiatus i talk about various
countries of the world global issues and
so on if you like educational videos
like this one then check out the
geofocus channel the link is in the
description and pinned comment of this
video
and now back to features of armenian
for learners of armenian the language
seems to have a steep learning curve at
the beginning because of its challenging
script and sounds some armenian letters
can be easily confused with others as
they are distinguished only by a single
different stroke that might be hard to
see depending on the font also in
writing armenian has long strings of
consonants in a row with no vowels
between them they're not exactly
consonant clusters because in speech
schwa vowels are normally inserted which
separate the consonants but those vowels
are not written which makes these words
hard to read even for native speakers
when they encounter a new word from what
i hear for example this word meaning
conscience
in writing it looks like one syllable
with a cluster of five consonants at the
beginning but in speech it has three
syllables when you consider the schwa
sounds so when learning armenian you
can't just learn the alphabet and then
be able to read any word you also need
to get used to the syllable structure of
the spoken language so you know where
the schwa sounds go
as for the actual consonants themselves
most of them are not too difficult or
unusual though english speakers might be
unfamiliar with sounds like
and
for example and there's a phonemic
distinction between unaspirated and
aspirated stops aspirated stops being
accompanied by a puff of air
most english speakers are not conscious
of the difference between unaspirated
and aspirated consonants because in
english there are variations of the same
consonant that are used depending on the
surrounding sounds so separating the two
variations and treating them as separate
consonants can be a challenge aside from
such initial challenges the biggest
challenge with armenian might be the
difference between its two standard
varieties and its widely varying
dialects but let's focus on eastern
armenia and start with a few basic words
and phrases
hello bhartiv this is informal in more
formal speech it's boring
or you could use a greeting that's
specific to the time of day good morning
[Music]
means good and luis means light
notice that the adjective is placed
before the noun when it's part of the
noun phrase
good afternoon
or means day
note that bharev is often used instead
good evening
evening note that adjectives only have
one form regardless of the noun number
case or gender actually armenian has no
grammatical gender so we have a good or
kind child
good or kind children
notice that the adjective doesn't change
for the plural ner is a plural suffix
which is normally used on polysyllabic
nouns on monosyllabic nouns it's usually
nouns in armenian take a number of
suffixes in this order stem plural
suffix case ending definite suffix or
possessive suffix we already have the
first two
denounce them
the plural suffix
is the nominative case which has no case
ending but if it were a direct object it
would normally be in the dative case and
look like this
and there could be a possessive suffix
on the end too yes
meaning your children as a direct object
there used to be seven noun cases in
armenian but now there are five
nominative and dative which i just
mentioned ablative instrumental and
locative there's a difference in case
depending on whether a noun is human or
non-human when they're the direct object
human nouns take the dative case while
non-human nouns take the nominative case
i love my child
is in the dative case with a first
person singular possessive suffix i love
my job
is in the nominative case with a first
person singular possessive suffix in the
first and second person singular
possessive in other words for my and
your there are possessive suffixes that
can be used but there are also
standalone possessive adjectives that
can be used they come before the noun
which has a definite article suffix so
let's adjust those sentences we saw
before i love my child yes
i love my job
means my the definite article suffix is
um like this after a vowel and uh after
a consonant
there's no strict word order in armenia
as in these sentences the default word
order is sov subject object verb with
the auxiliary verb coming after the main
verb but the relationship between words
is indicated by cases and postpositions
so the word order can change so for
example if we take the first sentence it
could be yes
which is svo yes
which is svo with the auxiliary verb
before the main verb
which is osv this word order is less
commonly used but is possible
changes in order can emphasize different
parts of the sentence for example in
this order my child is emphasized in
this order with the auxiliary verb and
main verb reversed the thing before the
auxiliary verb is emphasized in this
case i
and this one doesn't have any particular
emphasis one limitation is that an
auxiliary verb can never come at the
beginning of a sentence another
limitation is that phrases can't be
separated so sedumen can be m
but the two words can't be separated by
other elements of the sentence armenian
is also pro-drop which means that the
subject pronoun is not necessary unless
you want to emphasize who the subject is
what's your name the informal way to say
this is
is the word for name with the second
person singular possessive suffix inch
means what
means is it's the third person singular
form of the armenian copula verb which
is also an auxiliary verb
the more formal way to say this is inch
best says
pes means how
is the plural form of you in the dative
accusative form but it's also used for
the singular and polite speech dimel
means to refer or address and is the
infinitive form so there's no auxiliary
verb
my name is david
again annun is the word for name and
is the first person singular suffix
meaning my
and again e means is
remember that possession could also be
shown with a standalone possessive plus
the definite article suffix
i arrived yesterday
word for word it's yesterday i am come
here
means yesterday m on its own means i am
it's the first person singular form of
the copula verb but this verb is also
used as the auxiliary verb for armenian
verb tenses in the default word order
the auxiliary verb comes after the main
verb but in this case it comes before it
which puts emphasis on the previous word
meaning yesterday note that there is no
standalone personal pronoun for i in
this sentence because as i mentioned
before armenian is pro-drop because this
auxiliary verb is conjugated for i we
know who the subject is and the personal
pronoun is not necessary yequel is the
perfect participle of the verb gal
meaning to come in most verb tenses the
main verb is not conjugated for the
subject the auxiliary verb is conjugated
and the main verb is a participle form
the verb phrase in this sentence has
past meaning but is the present perfect
form the present perfect is formed with
the perfective participle plus the
present tense of the auxiliary verb
i've started to eat or i started to eat
the past perfect is formed with the
perfective participle plus the imperfect
tense of the auxiliary verb
i had started to eat
the present tense is formed with the
present participle plus the present
tense of the auxiliary verb
i'm starting to eat the imperfect tense
is formed with the present participle
plus the imperfect tense of the
auxiliary verb
i was starting to eat the future tense
is formed with the future participle
plus the present tense of the auxiliary
verb
i will start to eat the future perfect
is formed with the future participle
plus the imperfect tense of the
auxiliary verb
i will have started to eat
the one tense in armenian that has its
own standalone conjugation without the
auxiliary verb is the ars tense or past
tense
i started to eat
there's a pattern to how we get the
different verb forms the infinitive ends
in el or al
as you can see in the infinitive for eat
the infinitive for start is
if you take away the l ending you get
the present stem the present stem plus
um gives us the present participle the
aerist or past stem is the same as the
present stem but for verbs ending in al
the suffix ats is added the era stem
plus l gives us the perfect participle
the infinitive plus the suffix u gives
us the future participle
where's the cafe
means where this little diacritic here
is the question mark used in armenian
it's placed over the last vowel in the
question word
here we see e again which means is
and
here it's in the nominative case with a
definite article suffix
the cafe is over there
is a demonstrative pronoun meaning over
there armenian has a three-way
distinction here i stare there meaning
away from the speaker but near the
listener
and over there meaning away from both
the speaker and the listener
i don't drink alcohol
word for word it's alcohol i don't drink
notice again that this sentence doesn't
have a personal pronoun because the
subject is obvious from the conjugation
of the auxiliary verb
is the present participle of
meaning to drink
and ch
is the first person singular negative
form of the copula verb or auxiliary
verb which means to be so it means am
not
notice that the negative form of the
auxiliary verb comes before the main
verb and not after it like affirmative
auxiliary verbs often do
is a negative prefix that can be added
to any form of this verb and also to the
ars tense or past tense form of verbs in
general
form of the verb
meaning to finish and it has the same
negative prefix
literally means homework
means home as an adjective
it's related to the noun for home or
house
this word has cognates in many
indo-european languages like latin domus
from which we get the english word dom
russian dom and others
means work this is the nominative form
with the first person singular
possessive suffix
earlier in the video i talked about
influences on armenian especially
ancient ones but it's interesting to
note that rather than the extensive use
of greek loanwords and roots that are
used in other indo-european languages
armenian often coins new words or calcs
using armenian roots for example this
word meaning telephone it was coined
using the armenian root hera meaning
tella or far plus the root jose meaning
to speak
then there's this word
meaning dialogue it was coined from yes
meaning to
plus
from jose again meaning to speak plus
a suffix that forms abstract nouns and
then there's this word
meaning logic it consists of the root
meaning firm or solid plus ban
meaning word or speech plus utsuyun the
abstract noun suffix again
armenian is not a very widely spoken
language but it's an important part of
the identity of armenian people around
the world and it's also fascinating as a
unique language isolate within the
indo-european language family and as a
language that's come into contact with a
wide variety of other languages both
influencing them and being influenced by
them
if you're a speaker of armenian how
similar is your native dialect to the
standard variety used in your community
and whether you use eastern armenian or
western armenian how well do you
understand the other variety
special thanks goes out to the langfocus
patreon supporters especially the ones
whose names appear right here on the
screen they are the top tier patreon
supporters so many extra special thanks
go out to them armenia lies on the edge
of the caucasus region and has come into
contact with various caucasian languages
check out this video to learn more about
the languages of the caucasus there are
parts of this video that will blow your
mind
you